oh so one more question would you be
mark wrong instead of writing and or
can you just write a comment
is it clear
no it's not clear and which which i
think i hope answers the question right
if it's not clear like and there is a
difference between and
and or in different contexts right what
does the common actual sense the answer
is it doesn't represent anything and it
kind of depends on the context which is
why it's ambiguous which is why it's not
a good thing if there can only be one
thing then it's fine but if it can be
and or all then it's better not to use
it
i would always use the word and or the
word or
wherever i needed those the one
exception and it's relevant to this is
if for instance you're solving a tree
equation
and it's got
it's got like you know eight solutions
or something like that okay and you're
listing them all out and you're not this
is pretty much the only case where
you're not expected to say this or this
or this or this or this you can just
list them with commas but that's pretty
much it and then you're going to say
this one
um
yes this is true
okay okay i'll talk about it in more
detail when we come up against another
spot where it's relevant but um it's
easier if i show you the context last
question
jack says why the teacher wrote solution
or a comma
so then wouldn't this comma
well see
all involved
a comma is better than nothing
cora is better than nothing so like you
know for instance okay x
greater than five
um x
less than three okay this this just
looks confused it's like i have two
answers
i don't know which one it is okay at
least a comma kind of implies i mean
both of these in some way but it's not
clear what way that means right now in
this case a number cannot be greater
than five or less than three at the same
time there's no number which satisfies
that so this must be at all
right but if i were to go the other way
if i were to say you know x is greater
than three x is less than five think
about this now okay
if i say or
i say or
don't shout out but just think what
numbers satisfy that second line what
numbers satisfy this statement and the
answer is
any number you like will satisfy those
right because think let's think about a
number like uh four is an obvious one
okay so it does this one and does that
one same time great how about a number
like zero
zero is less than five it's not greater
than three but doesn't matter i have or
which means one or the other just one is
fine right so this inequality looks like
this
right here's zero three
five right so less than five would mean
this way
okay
greater than three would mean this way
and look i've got the whole number line
covered so oreo values so in this case
if what you really meant
if what you really wanted
was this
so right and it's about to catch you out
on something oh okay oh far out
there you go if that's what you really
meant okay
then you would have to say x greater
three and and x is less than five at the
same time right um the fancy word for
this is it's either a union that's the
or or it's an intersection which is the
end but we'll get more into that when we
deal with um
uh this becomes a way bigger deal rather
than like oh it's a little bit of a
technicality it becomes a big deal when
we have a look at 2d regions inequality
regions where you've got xs and wires
flying around